this is home to the sign singable
council this is design singable councils
logo this is design Singapore councils
security count this is a video about
design Singapore Council but what is
design Singapore Council in 2003 the
Singapore government set up design
Singapore council and the 11 years later
National Design Center was opened be
coming home to design Singapore council
design Singapore council has worked with
a lot of people product an industrial
designer fashion designer architect
creative director creative director
another creative director design
Singapore Council has enabled so many
design projects from Singapore Design
Week the president's Design Award the 50
years of Singapore design to 1000
Singapore's
to alchemists to keepers to Singapore
icons to a great design Singapore
council was involved in that these
projects are in Singapore and everywhere
in the world Paris Milan Shanghai
Hangzhou New York London Copenhagen
Seoul and of course anywhere with
internet connection all these
initiatives helped to put a piece of
Singaporean design across the world
and National Design Center is just so
involved in getting you to open your
mind to design thinking rapid
prototyping public service
transformation user empathy design
ethnography hackathons and storyboarding
ideation workshops master classes user
experiences 3d printing user testing
forums exhibitions talks courses film
screenings everything starts somewhere a
National Design Center is where
everything starts this is where design
appreciation happens this is National
Design Center where the right people are
introduced at the right time using the
right programs and services you just
need to be at the right place or you can
simply be here this is the Singapore
that design singable Council and
National Design Center scene a place for
design and innovation for the future of
Singapore just come before 9:00 p.m. the
cards very soon
you